few of the monsters that Evolution
created have been so successful at
hurting us as the variola virus
responsible for smallpox the Carnage it
caused was so terrible and merciless
that it compelled humankind for the
first time to act truly globally it was
one of the greatest wins of our species
over the ancient powers of nature all
made possible by cows
[Music]
variola is a virus a tiny machine that
only seeks to reproduce itself evidence
of it has been found in Egyptian mummies
and in writing from India and China as
old as 3000 years
1 300 years ago smallpox killed up to a
third of Japan's population by the 1600s
it was one of the major causes of death
worldwide in late 18th century Europe it
killed four hundred thousand a year
every third person who went blind did so
because of this virus even in the 20th
century a hot second ago in history it
still killed at least 300 million people
smallpox is an abusive monster that
returns over and over and over again
killing maiming and disrupting societies
how could variola be so incredibly
deadly for so long and how could we have
forgotten its horror so quickly in 2023
there are only two Laboratories left
where the living virus is officially
stored for research in Kosovo Russia and
Atlanta USA which is certainly a good
idea because what could possibly go
wrong
let's say that through an unfortunate
series of events the virus got out and
you got infected what would happen to
you
how smallpox kills
variola is highly infectious and catches
a ride in small droplets you breathe in
immediately it begins to infect the
cells that line your throat and starts
killing them to cause chaos why
to trick your body into giving it a lift
whenever cells in your body die of
violent death your immune cells
immediately stream to the site of
infection to help out in this case that
back fires horribly as immune cells
begin cleaning up dead cells eating
viruses and killing infected cells
variola infects a crucial cell of your
immune system your dendritic cells
intelligent cells that gather
information and leave the battlefield to
get help they enter your lymphatic
system a highway Network that spans your
entire body and connects hundreds of
immune bases in these bases your heavy
defenses are activated and should be the
last place an enemy would want to invade
but variolo wants to get here for about
12 days the virus quietly infects
civilian and immune cells jumping from
cell to cell infecting more and more of
them at some point a critical threshold
is reached and variola starts its attack
for real millions of viruses use the
lymphatic highway to spill into your
blood and organs infecting your whole
body
suddenly variola is everywhere
but despite This Global attack your
adaptive immune system is struggling to
wake up your immune cells look for and
use critical transmitters called
interferons to mobilize the body against
viruses interferons as the name suggests
interfere significantly slowing down
virus infections but also quickly
activating billions of antivirus weapons
but variola is able to deactivate
interferons which stuns the antivirus
side of your defense system other
systems would usually help like the
complement system a sort of mobile
Minefield that can destroy viruses but
variola manages to shut this down too
and so with Little Resistance variola
spreads everywhere and infects billions
of your cells all over your body among
the infected are your capillaries the
smallest blood vessels in your body
which die in great numbers all this
death activates an immune cell that you
really don't need right now but that's
attracted by death the neutrophil
normally an efficient killer of Invaders
Great and Small it's not very effective
against smallpox and even worse
neutrophils fight by vomiting deadly
chemicals which kills even more of your
cells
on top of that they order inflammation
fluids streaming from your blood vessels
into your tissue all over your body as
first Millions then billions of your
cells die you get a rash that only gets
worse and worse
pass and cellular junk fills it up as
your body swells up with hundreds of
lesions all over your skin and inside
even on your organs all filled with
billions of variola viruses now the
critical phase begins as you fight for
survival you burn up in a high fever
thousands of Battlegrounds drain your
blood of fluid that streams into your
tissue and organs blood clotting appears
all over your body while floods of
toxins from dead cells build up and can
cause organs to fail your lungs fill up
with fluid making it harder and harder
to breathe one of two things happens now
either your immune system wrestles back
control heavy weapons have been
dispatched killing infected cells
cleaning up the thousands of infections
one by one killing variola wherever it
can be found so you can slowly begin to
recover the immune system will forever
remember variola making you immune
forever or you die overwhelmed by the
infection and your immune system's Panic
reaction to the bodywide infection about
a third of people who contract smallpox
don't survive and if you survive you'll
very likely branded by scars and may
even lose your eyesight or hearing for
thousands of years this terrible disease
ravaged the world living death and
destruction traumatized and maimed
survivors until one day Humanity said
enough
why don't we have smallpox anymore
smallpox is one of the worst diseases
Humanity has ever known a murderer's
family destroying life-running monster
there was nothing you could do for the
infected but people noticed that if you
survived you were immune
so out of desperation they came up with
the dangerous practice of variation take
scabs from an infected person that had a
mild case of smallpox let them dry out
and grind them to a fine powder then
blow the powder up the nostril of a
patient or scratch their skin with it if
things went well they only got a mild
version of smallpox and gained immunity
against the disease variation probably
worked because it introduced variola in
a part of the body the virus wasn't
prepared for disabling most of its nasty
tricks and because the inoculation was
left to dry out that damaged the virus
so it couldn't cause the full disease
unfortunately two to three percent of
all patients still died because they got
the smallpox or suffered other diseases
as a result of treatment still smallpox
was such a horrible and to some degree
unavoidable disease that people took the
risk for themselves and their children
varilation spread around the globe while
variola continued to kill Millions a
victory over the virus only became a
real possibility when scientists
realized that the it wasn't necessary to
vary late with the real smallpox disease
but much safer to use material from
cowpox a variant that affected surprise
cows
a truly revolutionary step and only a
few years later this led to one of
humankind's most outstanding
achievements vaccinations The Innovation
was simple instead of using the real
virus to train the immune system use a
related virus car parks that was only
mild but also gave you immunity
still it would take another 200 years
countless individuals fighting the
monster where they could delivering
vaccines to the most remote places on
Earth all the while the disease ravaged
on killing over 300 million people in
the 20th century alone in 1966 the World
Health Organization decided that
Humanity had to come together in a final
major effort a global smallpox News
network based on residents in hotspots
was created tackling local outbreaks of
the virus cases were encircled vaccines
given preventing further spread
smallpox only infects humans so if we
stopped the human transmission chain we
would start the virus
the last naturally occurring infection
was in 1977 and in 1980 just shy of 200
years since the first vaccine was used
smallpox was declared eradicated variola
the scourge of humanity was dead no more
children would be killed by it no more
mothers or brothers or uncles or cousins
it's hard to convey to people around
today what an incredible win this was
one of the cruelest most dangerous
monsters that has hunted us for
literally Millennia was slain by us Apes
with pointy needles
today we live in a time of Enlightenment
none of us alive today are haunted by
the Spectra of smallpox this light is
not natural it was set in the Sky by the
sheer will of humankind wanting to be
safe from the monsters haunting us
but because we live without them we
forget that they ever existed and that
they are real
that the diseases might reawaken or new
ones might be brewing in jungles wet
markets or Laboratories ready to strike
us once more
we forget what an Incredible Gift
vaccines are and how hard we had to
battle to get them we are still
protected by the light but it's cooling
each and every day and we owe it to
those who will come after us to make
sure it doesn't go out
we killed one monster we can do it again
this video was supported by open
philanthropy
do you want to continue learning about
the fascinating world of biology we've
got you let's take a real close look at
the human body this is an arm and this
is a human cell the microscopic stage
where everything happens where all the
important battles are fought and where
you are constantly built over and over
again even though it's the smallest unit
of life the cell is extremely complex
but don't worry we managed to fit
everything you need to know on a single
poster and in true quartz exact fashion
it's easy to understand and even easier
on the eyes
grasping a complex topic is much easier
when it's presented in exciting ways the
poster was researched and designed in
collaboration with molecular biologist
James Gurney so its expert approved and
contains all the latest cutting-edge
science about organelles their function
and their place in the cellular world we
love bringing science into your home
with our videos and we're so excited
whenever we get to do it literally
that's why we take hundreds of hours to
create our science posters all
researched with care and crafted With
Love by us here at corsica's Art we love
having such a curious audience and we
want to inspire you and all the verbs in
your life to learn all about biology
space humans and life itself get the
human cell poster now exclusively on the
courts exact shop and support the kurz
gazant vision of sparking curiosity
when
[Music]
foreign